the problem fhe sooo very very easy okay
so you have the list of ingredients this
is for better una cross step outside una
torta so we have to make four times that
amount so gooseneck see you then well
since you are six I think you should
multiply the weight by 4a 9/6 so that
each of you has a chance to make up a
little bowl of talking you're going to
mix the dry ingredients that would be la
Farina no tu cara mia vita each salad a
minim yes you know this out of it they
are many kind of sauce haha men we don't
you think this salad I forgot it I
forgot inside inside yes Oh ducato o3d
min min t.t ha ha evening pika pika yes
go with it lebara EG morning go to Jared
any money and you add them to the guy
dry ingredients by your rock we want to
be sure that the Buddha remains cold
turkey bedrock check your Bora yes Fred
and you will cut it in cubes and you
will add it afterwards so you first put
all the dry ingredients in a bookshop
you wanna buy me take it orally guava
what's to early
Twala do over can also be set as Russell
glow yellow cross the channel we call it
also and then we will add the butter and
the idea is that you really just want to
put everything together super fast you
will need to need it for something like
30 seconds not more you remember the
same thing we did with the special honor
so like you will have this little pieces
you to like this with your fingers and
then as when they start to come together
the dough starts to come together you
just make a little bow wrap it in
transparent how do you call it in
plastic wrap around yes Ryan bra and
then we put it in the refrigerator to
rest so basic separada that humans that
women is in yonker go home cal 12 ear
also pushing we need only again we sorta
so no they yes they roasted thanks Josie
but we can keep girl moment your honor
we can make many guns
yeah and Judy Indiana let you continue
to server I'm gotcha miscellany okay and
get their eyes from go Chuck una good
chap is a drama ok ok this one goes
choice sorry usually I think people love
it how was it hard oh yeah oh where are
you going to put my next year right
everything wrong oorah 45 ish it's a
pearl a finder's day yay oh yeah not all
the power and off to the bar and not OBX
are the same rightful so if this happens
there are two options you know it's not
sticking together but we don't want to
overmix so you still want to give it
from it and at this point you have two
choices either you add some of the white
that we kept or you can add some super
children so I would suggest to make half
and half
right so there's a danger or do it back
up the eggs okay i thinka okay Xena
because it's not sticking yet Betty
together using all our pasta frolla
snips ago a fellow I gather it should
stay that we got a girl at least our
midst laura is community or one up to a
day need to make a lot you can also
freeze it and use it the month after in
a month from now so in the meantime we
can prepare luckily my bestie teaira
yeah so no sign bread twirly baba twirly
Farina to kuro venom so nuna peninsula
in a pot de sonia miss Kirara it worldly
on la Farina a bloodsucker mistress
amber in the meantime you can warm up
Thank Andara not then we want you to be
warm but not boiling but or okay you can
put 1 go chop d Vania nothing so one
example and that stuff is going to be
very dedicated you will have to make
some hot milk with the hope the sugar
and
egg mix okay gently keep mixing and the
idea is that you want to keep within the
same direction okay and you put it down
on fire like medium heat until it
thickens and this should take really a
few minutes not too long we say when
when I la crema past each era sometimes
doesn't come out very well so we say
that la crema add-in vicita impact Tita
Sol own faso is a crazy person these
artists in English when somebody's crazy
a little bit using this mean this or
like this somebody was crazy fatso and
we say that la crema at impact Sita it
got crazy if we didn't come out right so
there are many reasons why people cannot
write one reason could be that we used
eggs that were too cold you want X to be
a competitor I'm getting a room
temperature yet the reason why I start
mixing one direction and that means in
the other has a work or maybe you
overcooked it so there are different
that's why I got some extra milk just to
be sure that food c'est la crema
competition we can read more
Oh
50 grand flowers super super slowly and
yeah you do it I really dish or and you
keep on the same direction okay here we
go then one of them is in there with you
the thing is not gonna go crazy so you
will need a little bit of flour on the
counter or the ways it feels differently
and also you will need to deliver into a
flour your rolling papers so the river
though we flatten without half a
centimeter
we have a perfect finna bust each other
you see the consistency knife at sita
happen what you do you simply take your
dad or develop in the mouth okay well
you look that you want to remove yes oh
okay because the idea is that something
out and then you wake up in some strips
and you would put the street and create
a sort of a lattice okay
that's not doesn't make you smile that's
pretty good hahaha great where you can
work it yeah give me the only weird like
normal look